[Musica]
buonasera buonasera a anche a bolzano
salutato ok allora credo che se ci fosse
stato qua dante al mio posto
parlando di leggerezza avrebbe iniziato
così col suo trentatreesimo canto al
versetto 145 l'amor che move il sole e
le altre stelle perché la gravità
sostanzialmente esattamente questo una
forza che fa muovere tutto no almeno in
questo luogo che noi abitiamo
allora io voglio proprio partire da
questo mi piace studiare moltissimo
l'etimologia delle parole alla gente
litiga ormai per tutto anche sul senso
delle cose allora quando non volete
litigare con qualche d'uno su un'idea
lifton consiglio andate a studiare
l'etimologia della parola e scoprirete
che quella la verità assoluta da quello
non si scappa tutto il resto è solo per
conquistare qualcosa che non è tuo e ti
o inventare una scusa per prenderlo
magari poi ne parleremo quindi che cos'è
la gravità la gravità la parola gravità
deve ad altino gravis che significa
pesante
allora adesso spia nel dubbio quando
voglio parlare di cose che non conosco
mi metto a studiare e vado sui lumini
dicevo sul vocabolario vado su wiki pd a
vado su testi e vi leggo una cosa la
gravità è detta anche forza peso ed è
una forza universale che agisce su ogni
cosa dell'universo
ogni oggetto è dotato di massa esercita
questa forza sugli altri corpi anch'essi
dotati di massa attraendoli tale forza
varia a seconda della massa dei corpi
stessi maggiore la massa maggiore la
forza esercitata quindi la terra è
l'oggetto più pesante del mondo a noi
noto infatti la terra tra i tutti gli
altri oggetti infinitamente più piccoli
verso il suo centro ed è questo il
motivo per cui ogni cosa che viene
lasciata cadere si dirige verso il basso
dunque verso il centro del nostro
pianeta con una velocità pari a quella
che viene definita accelerazione
gravitazionale chi non ha capito questa
cosa e willy il coyote lo ricordate
perché wile coyote
vivo se vuole mangiare beep beep e
finisce sempre attratto da una forza
molto più potente lui perché willy il
coyote non studia cosa ignora ignora una
legge si parla infatti di legge di
gravità e la legge fino a che qualcuno
dimostra il contrario è uguale per tutti
questa legge però si può in qualche
maniera rompere io stasera proverò a
provocarmi a suggestionare nella
direzione del tentativo di alleggerirci
e ci metto anch'io cercando riflettere
su che cosa possa farvi compiere questo
atto magico
spero di arrivare fino in fondo nel
rispetto del tempo perché vero svelarvi
significato di questa immagine
guardatela è per un istante fotografate
da tanto molto clemente non coglierete
quella che è la differenza fra queste
due figure basta tempo scaduto il poco
occupa un posto immenso guardate questo
spazio fisico
noi siamo tutti attratti da ciò che
vediamo nessuno di noi attratto da una
cosa molto più grande che c'è qua dentro
che lo spazio vuoto ed è un gran peccato
perché io stasera vado a riflettere
proprio con voi su questo
pensate al punto che è stato studiato
alla fisica che se si riducesse tutto lo
spazio che c'è negli atti di materia
protone elettroni spazio vuoto di cui
sono fatti tutti i corpi di tutti gli
esseri umani sul pianeta tutta l'umanità
si ridurrebbe a una zolletta di zucchero
e nel frattempo ci massacriamo per tutto
che cos'è la forza di gravità lì dove tu
poggi il tuo sguardo che cos'è la forza
di gravità
ciò a cui tu attorno al quale tu
costantemente ruote noi lottiamo attorno
a delle idee attorno a quali the ruota
la nostra vita attorno a quali idee
ruota la tua vita attorno a quali
emozioni ruota la tua vita attorno a
quali gesti ruota la tua vita perché
quello è il tuo personalissimo centro di
gravità
la fisica scoperto ciò che ormai da
migliaia di anni hanno scoperto
tantissime tradizioni religiose di tutti
i popoli illuminati che hanno abitato
questo pianeta
la vita esteriore è una proiezione della
nostra condizione interiore
lui è come singoli individui lui è come
umanità pensando al pianeta per esempio
ne abbiamo un problema enorme in questo
momento noi siamo tristemente rispettosi
per questo luogo che ci abita tanto per
incominciare
dopodiché siamo anche rispettosi degli
altri abbiamo scritto a metà del secolo
scorso una carta la carta dei diritti no
dove sono stati elencate tutte una
quantità di libertà che si dovevano
garantire a qualunque altro nostro
simile sul pianeta e sono stati
affermati una quantità infinita di
diritti che dovevano essere riconosciuti
a tutti in realtà poi noi facciamo delle
guerre dove uccidiamo delle madri
costringendo i loro figli a disegnare la
sagoma della loro madre sul pavimento a
togliersi rispettosamente le scarpe a
ritrovare una posizione fetale a
metterci nel grembo di nostra madre che
non c'è più
noi siamo esseri che trafficano in
organi ok abbiamo vergogna e pudore nel
fare tutto questo noi abbiamo fatto
abbiamo attivato il processo della
globalizzazione ve lo dico da economista
ma anche da economista vi dico che tutti
gli anni al world economic forum a
ginevra dove si riuniscono i più grandi
statisti di questo pianeta vengono
condivisi dai dati sulla distribuzione
della ricchezza
sappiate che appartenete tutti a quelli
un per cento che possiede una ricchezza
pari se non maggiore al 99 restante per
cento di vostri simili che abitano
questo pianeta sappiate che l'anno
scorso 62 esseri umani aveva una
ricchezza pari ad altri 3 miliardi e
sappiate che l'anno prima erano 85 e
sappiate che nel 2010 erano 388 dal 2010
al 2016
siamo scesi da 388 a 62 quest'anno erano
88 uomini hanno una ricchezza pari alla
metà più povera del pianeta quindi la
favola che raccontiamo probabilmente
potrebbe questa volta ve lo dico da
studioso degli scenari futuri con
colleghi in tutto il mondo
non finire come noi ci auspichiamo in
piu se potesse bastare poi finiscono
pensiamo prandi leggerezza però per
leggere vi prima vi dico tutte le cose
brutte
il nostro pene formulato 215 billions di
debito pubblico
quando il che corrisponde a oltre 125
per cento della nostra capacità di
produrre ricchezza e solo negli ultimi
anni ha accumulato 70 di questi 215
quindi l'essere è stato capace di
dividere l'atomo non ha imparato ancora
dividere il pane e questa è una bella
pesantezza e soprattutto e iniziamo
arrivare al nodo della questione
noi iniziamo anna normalizzare a non
lasciarci più distrarre da fatti che non
hanno nulla di leggero
l'unica vera possibilità che la vita ci
sta donando in questo momento e deve
godere di questa opportunità è
esattamente la crisi martin tokin diceva
può essere che tu non sia responsabile
per la situazione in cui ti trovi ma lo
sarai se non farei nulla per cambiarla
allora io voglio condividere con voi la
possibilità di alleggerirci per cambiare
questo qualche cosa perché la battaglia
che dobbiamo combattere tutti in fretta
per i nostri figli è la lotta contro la
mediocrità cioè contro coloro che mentre
accadono delle cose scusate la volgarità
delle immagini perché è riuscito a
cogliere il contrasto tra ciò che gli
uomini fanno e ciò che i cani fanno è
quella di disinteressarci pensate che
tutta la sofferenza che c'è in giro per
il mondo viene in questo momento
ricondotta come i termini di
responsabilità alle banche che esercita
una pressione sulle corporation che la
esercita sui politici che vestano la
gente i lavori una banca la mi sono
domandato a lungo che cosa potessi fare
e mi sono inventato una cosa come
perdonate la parolaccia ho dato il mio
il mio narnia il mio mondo magico e mi
sono inventato una nuova prospettiva sul
concetto di economia
l'ho fatto cercando di capire se l'amore
potesse in qualche maniera essere
accolta dall economia sono andato spoke
abo lario e ho trovato una risposta
fantastica sono nato e del significato
della parola economia e ho trovato arte
di reggere e bene amministrare le cose
della famiglia e dello stato
c'è una parola strana qua dentro realtà
ce ne sono due una è arte l'arte è una
forma di è una disciplina che educa
l'essere umano al bello purtroppo
stasera non abbiamo tempo di parlarne ma
c'è una parola ancora più curiosa bene
se avessimo trovato arte di reggere
amministrare le cose della famiglia
dello stato non ci saremmo preoccupati
ma perché hanno messo bene non ti
confondere bene non significa redditizio
è un bene con la b maiuscola
quindi c'è la possibilità di essere
delle brave persone perché non ti costa
nulla
non ci costa nulla non di costa nulla
essere una buona persona
tenete conto che si confonde troppo
spesso l'economia con una transazione di
denaro per acquistare dei dei beni
prodotti o servizi in realtà noi adesso
stiamo facendo un atto economico io ti
offre un'idea tu mi paghi col tuo tempo
la tua attenzione se sia un politico tu
offri un programma elettorale verrà
ripagato con la fiducia con il voto se
sei un insegnante offre un programma
pedagogico verrà ripagato con
l'attenzione degli studenti
stessa cosa vale per un genitore è tutta
una transazione economica quindi la
provocazione che vi lancio e pillola
rossa o figlio alla blu perché pillola
blu chissenefrega resti nella tua catena
del valore comandè ray qualcheduno
verrai comandato da altri pillola rossa
c'è la possibilità di stare nel sistema
cambiando invertendo il paradigma che
non funziona più ve lo dico da studioso
degli scenari futuri
il mondo sta cambiando completamente
tutte le gerarchie verranno ribaltate
politica religione società famiglia
sessualità tecnologia non ho tempo di
dettagliare fi per un istante un atto di
fede
questo è interessante c'è un luogo dove
possiamo essere tutti molto migliori di
ciò che siamo
volete diceva se tratti un uomo per
quello che è e gli rimarrà così come se
tu lo tratti per quello che potrebbe
dovrebbe diventare egli certamente
diventerà ciò che potrebbe e dovrebbe
diventare di questo parlo nel mio libro
so che qua dovrebbe esserci sarei
onorato se qualcuno trovasse il tempo
alla pazienza di leggerlo
parlo dei nuovi eroi in un vero e lui
dice la siamo tutti in potenza siamo
tutti in realtà siamo solo costo coloro
i quali decidono di assumersi il loro
pezzo di responsabilità per contribuire
al cambiamento responsabilità significa
abilità di dare responso la vita ci sta
facendo domande nuove non possiamo
rispondere con paradigmi vecchi con
programma neurocognitivi vecchi se tu
vai a londra e deve attraversare la
strada
non puoi guardare a destra devi guardare
a sinistra
eppure il tuo cervello ti costringe
nonostante la tua intelligenza guardare
dalla parte sbagliata perché il tuo
programma è vecchio quindi qual è la
rivoluzione che è necessario oggi una ri
evoluzione una nuova evoluzione di uno
stato di coscienza che la tua volontà di
dare un contributo
esattamente come accade nell'uomo non
c'è bisogno di ritirarsi nei monasteri
vendendo la propria ferrari nell'uovo
quando il luogo viene crepato da fuori
sta per morire una vita in tutti i fatti
di uomini bisogna crepare i sistemi da
dentro perché esattamente come nell'uovo
nascerà una nuova vita il messaggio che
voglio condividere con voi e ci serve
leggerezza per cambiare un paradigma che
non regge più e rischia di collassare
questo per me e gravità zero è ripartire
anche perché dovete essere consapevoli
di una cosa c'è una legge che governa
l'universo quello che metti in circolo
ti ritorna questa non è filosofia
questa è scienza noi siamo legati da
molte più cose di quelle che ci separano
c'è qualche fisico quantistico in sala
no allora la sparo non ci credete
mandata a verificare al netto
dell'effetto della materia oscura i
fisici avrebbero scoperto che tutti gli
atomi di materia di cui è composto tutto
l'universo di universi mantengono una
memoria di quando tutti questi atomi di
materia erano l'unica cosa un istante
prima che avvenisse a patto che sia
avvenuto il big bang siamo tutti i fatti
di una materia che a memoria della
stessa materia di cui è fatto l'altro
uguale siamo tutti interconnessi gli uni
con gli altri
questo signore è uno scienziato
contemporaneo di einstein si chiama
dirac ha tirato fuori questa formula
se due sistemi interagiscono tra loro
per un certo periodo di tempo
porca miseria vedo male e poi vengono
separati non possono più non possiamo
più distinguere come i due sistemi
distinti ma in qualche modo sottile
diventa l'unico sistema quello che
accade a uno di loro continua ad
influenzare anche l'altro in cina
recentemente due particelle in
università hanno divise a milioni di
chilometri uno dall'altro al mutare
dell'una sono mutate le caratteristiche
anche dell'altra questa è scienza
io dipendo dalla signora io dipendo da
lei io dipendo da lui ci sono biologi in
sala che mestiere fate tanto poi ci sono
sempre poi vengono l'intervallo e ti
correggo nilo chiedo per quello siamo 7
miliardi quasi otto tra un po sul
pianeta non riusciamo a riprodurre un
sistema sociale economico sostenibile
che in realtà già ci appartiene
questo è il numero di cellule di cui è
fatto il nostro corpo non riesce neanche
a leggere il numero esatto per un certo
punto il cervello va in tilt e non
capisce quanti zeri sono sono milioni e
milioni di milioni che vi erano perfetto
se io mi taglio un polpastrello in
questo momento tra pochi minuti il
taglio verrà rimarginato perché tutto il
sistema che si chiama corpo fatto di
questo numero di cellere registra un
danno in periferia
vi ho fatto vedere dei bambini squartati
e ricuciti regista un danno in periferia
e si occupa di rim arginarlo perché
perché sa perfettamente che da quel
taglio potrebbe innescarsi che cosa
un'infezione che potrebbe compromettere
tutto
il sistema stesso la parte in periferia
che sia catania sia a bolzano
se si taglia contribuisce essa stessa
rimarginarsi perché sa che proprio da
lei potrebbe scaturire quel processo
un'infezione che potrebbe compromettere
il tutto esso stesso compreso perché
essendo così tanti in un corpo e così
pochi sul pianeta non riusciamo ancora
perché siamo pesanti quindi attorno
quali domande gravità la tua vita la mia
vita
la nostra vita einstein diceva io sto
qua le mie domande molto più tempo degli
altri quanto finché non trovo le
risposte
il mio maestro patrizio paoletti ma
insegnato oscar se non trovi una
risposta riformula la domanda perché
ogni domanda è già gravi da della sua
risposta
attorno quale centro di gravità ruota la
tua vita perché ci sono solo due giorni
importanti nella tua vita
quando sei nato come diceva mark twain e
quando è scoperto perché se 26
rispondere soprattutto la seconda la
prima mai senato lato alta sarà pesante
e non confondere la ricchezza la salute
bellezza quella leggerezza questo poeta
francese disse noi non siamo esseri
umani che fanno l'esperienza spirituale
noi siamo esseri spirituali che fanno
un'esperienza umana
quindi o viene attratto dalla terra o
viene attratto dal cielo quello che fa
la differenza è avere una vocazione uno
scopo un senso qualunque cosa tu faccia
nella vita ma purtroppo non c'è tempo
postino siamo poco più degli animali e
siamo poco meno degli angeli in mezzo
c'è la nostra volontà di essere delle
persone migliori
questa era la formula sottostante questo
è il principio alchemico sapete
dell'alchimia i veri maghi erano gli
altri tutti mago merlino era un
alchimista cioè delle persone che
possedevano la conoscenza la parola
magia deriva dal persona antico mag
che significa conoscere sapevano
trasmutare dei metalli gross grossolane
piombo in metalli nobili oro sapete qual
è la differenza fra questi due atomi di
materia semplicemente 3 elettroni tu sei
a tre elettroni dall'essere un angelo
dall'essere un essere perfetto un essere
con una volontà che contempli il bene di
tutti
un bene assoluto perché se c'è
continuiamo a cercare tutti solo il
nostro bene facendo economia litigheremo
ormai litighiamo anche per il senso di
dio che poi una bufala perché stiamo in
realtà combattendo per prenderci terreno
nostre accoppiarci con femmine non
nostre e schiavizzare gente che lavora
al nostro posto
il resto tutta la volta di telegiornale
quindi il mio messaggio è alleggeriamo
ci dobbiamo diventare dei maghi perché
siamo vicinissimi alla perfezione
purtroppo aveva voluto far vedere un
video bellissimo di picasso ma il tempo
ahimé è scaduto e quindi non potrò
vedere e non lo trovate anche sul web
perché introvabile e praticamente quasi
un'esclusiva non ve lo faccio vedere ma
vi lascio con la sua dichiarazione
picasso diceva quando l'ispirazione
arriverà mi troverà dipingendo questo
quadro vi avrebbe rivelato il senso di
questa cosa
gravità zero è restare nel flusso tu non
sai cosa accadrà tra un istante e ciò
che è già successo
non esiste già più esiste solo questo
istante e il pianeta in questo momento
ha bisogno di persone per bene non per
bene per il bene è l'unico vero bene è
il bene di tutti se puoi
come mi è stato insegnato e sto cercando
di fare fai della tua vita un dono e fai
di questo dono qualcosa di significativo
per l'insieme sarai leggerissimo perché
tanto la gente si dimenticherà di ciò
che avrei detto si dimenticherà di ciò
che avrei fatto
ma non si dimenticherà mai che come
l'avrei fatta sentire
sì leggero e fai sentire gli altri
leggeri buona vita
oscar e mondini grazie